what about TV shows that depend on
studio audiences well Rachel Smith has
more on that hey Rachel
hey there keV it is going to be a lot
more quiet on the set as Hollywood gets
back to work I really hope that we get
to a point where we can come back
together safely it's so crucial the
audience reaction to the dancing that
that's something we would love to keep
now we've got 200 people in our audience
who will never have that again I want to
go back to do our show for Wendy to
Kelly and Ryan everyone's expecting big
changes even if we have no audience I
can't wait to be in the same room with
you
a spokesperson for lied tells et they'll
be back from the studio without an
in-studio audience on September 8 Jun
legends one of the first to film a music
video in LA a so did Snoop Dogg and when
it comes to what happens in doors on
sets an entertainment industry task
force release guidelines recommending no
packed makeup trailers and staggered
mealtimes the buffet tables with you
know bagels and everything is not going
to be something we're gonna be seeing on
sets anytime soon
but what about those love scenes love
scenes on soaps are just the worst right
if they're gonna cut those I'm totally
fine with it there are no published
guidelines yet as far as how to do
intimate scenes I have no doubt that we
will be hearing more in that area CBS is
the bold and the beautiful is the first
broadcast series to go back to work
dawn diamant posted this pic from the
set as filming starts tomorrow
throughout Hollywood many casts and
their crew can expect to get tested one
to three times per week and have daily
temperature checks all monitored by a
production appointed who vat19
compliance officer there's probably
daily testing honestly because of that
how contagious this is you know what I'm
making the call absolutely there are
plans to resume chris pratt and bryce
dallas howard jurassic roles a minion is
the first major studio film to go back
to work they'll resume shooting July 6th
at Pinewood Studios in the UK the actors
must quarantine there for two weeks and
will be tested beforehand since Chris's
wife Catherine is due this summer that
could impact their time with a new baby
you know I appreciate that the folks who
are making Jurassic are doing it you
know with their eyes wide open and
really understand what we're facing here
we will be tested about two weeks prior
to arriving to the set here on more from
the ETS the oval told us her boss Tyler
Perry put out his own a 30 page set of
guidelines
Tyler's turning his Atlanta Studios into
camp quarantine where they'll all live
together when they return in July it
almost sounds like summer camps or
boring school or something like that
actually will be quarantined for 14 days
after the second test once we're on
campus and then once we're given the
all-clear then we can you know get to
the business of work welcome to be
world-famous Tyler Perry studios here in
Atlanta we've been to town there's 330
acre campus
it's bigger than Warner Brothers Disney
and Paramount Studios Lots combined it'd
be a lot of fun I'm praying that you
know he'll make history with this being
a success
[Music]